das ausgerechnet dieses Gesicht ihm in
Belgrad oft begegnet erschreckt ihr ja
cernov denn so erzählt er mir
seinetwegen musste er aus Russland
fliegen er hatte dort gegen den
kriegprotestiert er wurde festgenommen
er sah keine Zukunft mehr in Russland
er floh nach Belgrad doch richtig
Frieden ist hier nicht in Serbien ist
Propaganda Krieg es geht immer auch ums
Kosovo es geht um Ost oder West
es werden auch Kriegsverbrecher
verherrlicht Ilja will das nicht stehen
lassen vor einem Monat übermalte er
anti-ukrainische Hetzparolen unter dem
Bild der wagnergruppe fünf Serben
umzingelten ihn ihn
Maske da Maske Putina
[Musik]
er konnte fliehen aber er fürchtet
weitere Attacken es erinnert an Russland
es ist die Folge von Propaganda
krasse Elternabend kann
[Musik]
Serbien und Russland sind sich
traditionell nah beide Völker sind
slawisch und orthodox
auf serbisch nationalistischen Demos
sind die serbisch-russischen Farben
stets dabei denn Russland stand Serbien
bei in den Jugoslawien kriegen und tut
es auch heute in der Kosovo-Frage
deshalb stehen im Krieg gegen die
Ukraine viele Serben auf russischer
Seite die Quoten starken Privatsender in
Serbien happy und pink greifen das auf
in ihren populären Talkshows sitzen vor
allem pro russische Gesprächspartner
erklärt
das Putin gegen das faschistische
regimentier vorgehen musste und spricht
von ethnischen Säuberungen gegen Russen
keiner widerspricht
die Ukraine habe ich Hitler den Rekord
im Bücher verbrennen abgenommen
Zweiten Weltkrieg
vom westlichen Faschismus
unterbrochen wird die Propaganda durch
Werbung häufig für deutsche Supermärkte
und deutsche Produkte
es sind Millionen von Euro mit denen da
deutsche Unternehmen russische
Propaganda Stützen sagt Rascha nedelico
von der NGO zirka ihr media-monitoring
wird auch von der Deutschen Botschaft
unterstützt
money from the companing helping the
scores sowie asking them to help us Bild
stronger resilien Serbia and to becomes
family
Lidl gibt am meisten aus auf welchem
Sender Lidl wird entscheidet man nur auf
der Basis von Marketing Kennzahlen so
heißt es die meisten Unternehmen machen
es ebenso dabei hätte das deutsche Wort
Gewicht der serbische Präsident
Alexander Vucic eröffnet gern und oft
deutsche Firmenstandorte denn sie sind
sehr oft sehr groß
serbische Unternehmen sind es in der
Regel nicht beim großkonditor stanewski
Arbeiten 160 Menschen trotzdem es geht
voran zeigen aber Serbien könnte nicht
überleben so sagt der selbst ohne
Deutschland ohne Komponist
selbst ist der häufigste Gast in den
großen Privatsendern bei Milo miramaric
happy TV Chefredakteur sitzt der oft
stundenlang hier muss er keine
kritischen Fragen fürchten und bisher
hat ihn auch die anti-westliche
Propaganda nicht gestört zum Beispiel
diese
deutsche Außenministerin sei früher
professionelle Prostituierte gewesen man
hört keine Korrektur uns gegenüber redet
Maritsch das klein es sei halt live und
Jonas
Kiste tot
dein Zyniker der Einschaltquoten ein
anti-talkshow selbst unglaubwürdig aber
sie prägen sein Publikum und Lidl und Co
finanzieren das Happy sei bekanntermaßen
pro russisch sagt auch Russisch selbst
auf meine Frage entschuldigt sich für
die Äußerung zur Außenministerin
das soll wohl ein Seitenhieb sein auf
den Westen über Russlands Propaganda
haben ich ja und seine serbischen
Freunde eine Ausstellung organisiert ein
gutes Dutzend Besucher hier
hunderttausende dagegen bei Happy und
pink nach unserer Anfrage wurde nun
einige deutsche Marken Ihre Werbung
überdenken zum Beispiel Henkel DM und
Vileda für
Ilja wäre das ein kleiner Erfolg in
einem großen Propagandakrieg